[Music]
[Applause]
will you solemnly promise and swear to
govern the peoples of the United Kingdom
of Great Britain and Northern Ireland I
solemnly promise 32.
received the Royal scepter the Ensign of
kingly power and justice
[Music]
God Save the King
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
for the United Kingdom
foreign
[Music]
I mean
seventy years since the Queen's
coronation
[Music]
the capital welcomes people from all
corners of the world
[Music]
uh
absolutely excited ass can't wait to see
the correlation
I mean this is the most important event
for the world for lots and lots of years
it's just an event you can't miss
[Music]
amazing it's really important to be able
to be part of something like this
thing that will say my memory forever
participants in the pageantry
the public
dignitaries
the great and good all gather
[Music]
foreign
and then the first glimpse of the man
fulfilling his destiny
[Applause]
to become the 40th reigning monarch to
be crowned at Westminster Abbey
[Music]
anticipation solemnity and perhaps a few
nerves written on the king's face
[Music]
the king and queen traveled from
Buckingham Palace to Westminster Abbey
in the Diamond Jubilee State coach
complete with Heating and electric
windows
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
it is a short Journey but one that's
taken the new king more than half a
century to complete
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
but it's not always been a smooth
journey to this point waiting at the
Abbey the Duke of Sussex facing his
family for the first time since his
telol memoir
thank you
[Music]
today differences and difficulties
though are put to one side as the royal
family shows Unity
today
[Music]
foreign
in the congregation representatives of
causes close to the king's heart Role
Models those who've given to society
rubbing shoulders with royalty and world
leaders
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
the Queen's coronation gown designed by
Bruce Oldfield Ivory silver and gold a
coat-like dress embroidered with motifs
of wildflowers representing the couple's
love of nature
[Music]
the king wears his grandfather George
VI's Crimson robe of state with a new
Crimson coronation tunic
foreign
[Music]
it is the most solemn moment in a
Monarch's life a ceremony both ancient
and modern the king determined the
service Embraces tradition as well as
21st century values
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and then the ceremony begins watched by
Royal commentator Alistair Bruce
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
of arms leads Samuel Strachan child of
his Majesty's Chapel's Royal
who will address the game as children of
the kingdom of God we welcome you in the
Name of the King of Kings
in his name and after his example I come
not to be served but to serve
[Music]
we now move to the first part of the
coronation ceremony
this is when we identify that the king
is indeed the rightful sovereign
present unto you King Charles
your undoubted king
wherefore all you who I'll come this day
to do your homage and service are you
willing to do the same
God save King Charles
sir
to keep you ever mindful of the law and
the gospel of God
as they rule
for the whole life and government of
Christian princes
receive this book
the most valuable thing that this world
has to offer
here is wisdom
this is
the Royal law
these are
the Lively articles of God
the coronation oath has stood for
centuries
and is enshrined in law
are you willing to take the oath
I am willing
will you solemnly promise and swear to
govern the peoples of the United Kingdom
of Great Britain and Northern Ireland
your other Realms and the territories to
any of them belonging or pertaining
according to their respective laws and
customs
I solemnly promised her to do
will you to your power cause Law And
Justice in Mercy to be executed in all
your judgments I will
you to the utmost of your power maintain
the laws of God and the true profession
of the Gospel
will you to the utmost of your power
maintain in the United Kingdom the
Protestant reformed religion established
by law
will you maintain and preserve
invaluably the settlement of the Church
of England
and the doctrine worship discipline and
government thereof
as by law established in England
and will you preserve unto the Bishops
and clergy of England and to the
churches they're committed to their
charge all such rights and privileges as
by Lord do or shall appertain to them or
any of them
all this I promise to do
the things which I have here before
promised I will perform and keep so help
me God
your majesty
are you willing to make subscribe and
declare to the statutory accession
declaration oath
I am willing
I chose to solemnly and sincerely in the
presence of God profess testify and
declare that I am a faithful Protestant
that I will according to the true intent
of the enactments which secure the
Protestant succession to the throne
uphold and maintain the said enactments
to the best of my Powers according to
law
as The Quiet Things prevent us O Lord in
all our dealings
the two copies of the Oaths will be
brought forward by the law Champion or
the king to sign
this is the only time
the Monarch will write and sign a
written Covenant with his people
[Music]
my boys
the king will know
lead a prayer of his own
calling on God's mercy and compassion
God of compassion and mercy
whose son was sent not to be served but
to serve
give Grace that I may find in thy
service
perfect freedom
and in that freedom knowledge of thy
truth
grant that I may be a blessing to all
thy children
of every faith and belief
that's together we may discover the ways
of gentleness
and be led into the paths of peace
through Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
[Music]
for God is
[Applause]
[Music]
the king will not be divested of his
robe of state and prepared for anointing
a scream will come forward with
one trooper and five Guardsmen of the
household Division and will be held
around the coronation chair made in
1300. for King Edward the first
and then at the moment of anointing the
soldiers will buy their heads and the
hospital of Canterbury
will anoint the king's hands breast and
head
with holy oil
in the words of William Shakespeare of
Richard II
not all the water in the rough rude sea
can wash the bomb
from an anointed king
[Applause]
[Music]
please
comments
[Music]
rain again
foreign
[Music]
the King has been dressed first of all
in the colobium syndonis a very simple
white garment
warned We Believe by farmers in the
Byzantine Empire
and then the dalmatic
a gold coat
as he is prepared as they were priests
ready to celebrate Mass
and then the girdle is attached
the process of
the investiture with the regalia
that will ultimately lead to croning
will begin
receive these spurs symbols of military
honor and chivalry that you may be a
brave advocate for those in need
a Byzantine chant and sword
will now sing to evoke
the ancient traditions and to recall
those of the king himself through his
father
who was a prince of Greece
[Music]
in time the Lord president of the
council has replaced this order state
with the jeweled sword estate which will
be girded to the King by the Archbishop
after being
[Music]
and so direct and support thy servant
King Charles that he may not bear The
Sword in vain but may use it as the
minister of God to resist evil and
defend the good
through Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
[Music]
the jeweled sword of offering will be
placed into the king's right hand
[Music]
receive this kingly sword
may it be to you and to all who witness
these things a sign and simple not of
judgment but of Justice not of might but
of Mercy
the king will rise and the sword will be
attached to the girdle
can't believe
[Music]
with his sword do justice stop the
growth of iniquity protect the Holy
Church of God and all people of good
will
help and defend widows and orphans
restore the things that are gone to
Decay maintain the things that are
restored punish and reform what is amiss
and confirm what is in good order
that doing these things you may be
glorious in all virtue and so Faithfully
serve our Lord Jesus Christ in this life
that you may Reign forever with him in
the life which is to come amen
the king will stand
and will offer the sword at the altar
the dean of Westminster will receive it
the king will then return to the
coronation chair
the sword will be redeemed
and return to the Lord president of the
council
for the payment of a hundred Shillings
according to ancient customs
[Music]
the soul will then be drawn and carried
by the Lord president of the council
along with the other three swords here
three sorts of Justice including Katana
the one that presented we see to the
right with those three former Chiefs of
having staff
broken at the end
the armles will be brought
from the altar
by Lord camel and the King will touch
them
receive the bracelets of sincerity and
wisdom taken of the Lord's protection
embracing you on every side
the Rope Royal is now brought
made for the coronation of King George
IV in 1821.
it is supposed to represent the four
corners of the world
and to enfold the king
with wisdom
and
righteousness
and to be the Garment of salvation
first of all
the stall is placed on by the Prince of
Wales
still with the plant badges the United
Kingdom
and also the eagle
which is also on the robe
the clasp will be connected
at the chest of the King by his son the
Prince of Wales
receive this row
may the Lord clothe you with the robe of
righteousness and with the garments of
salvation
the Archbishop of armor and primate of
all Ireland and Metropolitan will now
bring the orb
to the Archbishop who will place it in
the king's right hand
it represents the cosmos
and Christ's Dominion
receive this all
set under the cross
and remember always that the kingdoms of
this world are become the kingdom of our
God and of his Christ
the ring will be brought from the altar
by the right on all Lord Patel
the king will touch the ring
receive this ring symbol of kingly
dignity and a sign of the Covenant sworn
this day
between God and King
King and people
the king will now be invested
with two scepters
one of power and one of Mercy but before
that
for his right hand that will take the
scepter of kingly power a glove to
remind him to be gentle
in the use of power
receive this glove that you may hold
Authority with gentleness and Grace
trusting not in your own power but in
the mercy of God
the scepter of kingly power is placed
into the king's right hand
receive the Royal scepter the end sign
of kingly power and justice
and the Raj of equity and mercy a symbol
of Covenant and peace
May the spirit of the Lord who anointed
Jesus at his baptism so anoint you this
day that you might exercise Authority
with wisdom and direct your councils
with grace that by your service and
Ministry to all your people
Justice and mercy may be seen in all the
Earth
king of kings and Lord of lords bless we
beseech thee this crown
and so sanctify thy servant Charles upon
whose head this day thou Dost place it
for a sign of Royal Majesty that he may
be crowned with thy gracious favor and
filled with abundant grace and all
princely virtues
through him who liveth and reigneth
Supreme Over All Things
one God World Without End
amen
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
firm
and hold fast from henceforth this seat
of Royal dignity
which is yours by the authority of
almighty God
May that same God whose Throne endures
forever
establish your throne in righteousness
that it may Stand Fast forevermore
I just in Archbishop of Canterbury
will be faithful and true and faith and
truth I will bear unto you our Sovereign
Lord defender of the faith and unto your
heirs and successors according to law
so help me God
I William Prince of Wales pledge my
loyalty to you and faith and truth I
will bear unto you as your lead man of
life and limb so help me God
I now invite
those who wish to offer their support to
do so
with a moment of private reflection
by joining in saying God save King
Charles at the end
or for those with the words before them
to recite them in full
I swear that I will pay true allegiance
to your majesty and your heirs and
successes according to law
so help me God
Save the King
Charles May the King live forever
receive this ring
a symbol of Royal dignity and a sign of
the Covenant sworn this day
May thy servant Camilla who wears this
Crown be filled by thine abundant grace
and with all princely virtues
reign in her heart O King of love the
being certain of thy protection she may
be crowned with thy gracious favor
through Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
receive the Royal scepter
receive the rod of equity
and mercy
May the spirit guide you in wisdom and
Grace
that by your service and Ministry
Justice and mercy may be seen in all the
Earth
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the Bishops are at the door
and we wait for the king to appear
foreign
[Music]
already yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Prince George playing his part as page
to his grandfather
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the ceremony over the Monarch murmurs a
thank you and then a show of relief that
his crowning Glory went without a hitch
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
for the congregation a moment of History
they will remember forever
absolutely remarkable enchanting an
extraordinary and brilliant
it was electric you could feel the
weight of the service on the king it's
solemn albeit joyful
we had a brilliant day out we both loved
it and it's going to be they will always
remember
there's so many times I could have burst
into tears for the sheer emotion of it I
thought the the whole service was
fantastic
[Music]
as his mother did after her coronation
the king and queen returned to
Buckingham Palace in the notoriously
uncomfortable 260 year old gold State
coach
[Music]
behind them other members of the Royal
Family
The Prince and Princess of Wales and
their children Louis on his best
behavior
all accompanied by 4 000 members of the
Armed Forces 19 military bands and 1 000
musicians
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
there hasn't been a military ceremonial
operation on this scale since the
funeral of Sir Winston Churchill
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
yes it rained almost a tradition in
itself this the third coronation in a
row where the heavens have opened
[Music]
despite the pump being trimmed back the
cost of the coronation has concerned
some there were protests and a handful
of arrests
shouts which would have been hard for
the king and queen to hear over the
cheers and music of the military bands
foreign
[Music]
with the weight of the crown on his head
and the weight of all his rolling tails
on his shoulders the king meets his
troops
Sailors soldiers and aviators salute the
newly anointed and crowned King it is a
confirmation of what the military
describe as the Inseparable bond between
the armed forces and the sovereign
[Music]
for the crowds their chance came to head
down the Mao to take up position
brolies and flags at the ready a
pageantry of plastic ponchos some Keener
than others to get to the front for the
moment they'd been waiting hours to see
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
the king's popularity has risen since he
ascended the throne Guided by his mother
over time he's won the respect of the
nation
he knows this kind of admiration cannot
be taken for granted
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
disappointment the fly past was trimmed
down because of the weather
although helicopters and the Red Arrows
still delighted those watching From
Below
[Applause]
[Music]
the Royal Family's relevance is being
questioned more than ever before perhaps
why the faces of the future appeared
beside the new king
[Applause]
[Music]
today the main question though was will
the royal couple respond to please for
an encore the answer came quickly
foreign
[Applause]
to see this once in a lifetime
experience making history it's the
patriotism it's brilliant it really is
it's really proud weather
we were here part of the history it was
amazing yes just being here you know
doing the coronation I think it's just
an absolutely incredible moment uh one
that I'm glad I got out of bed for in
the morning to come and Witness
[Music]
Charles has spent a lifetime learning
what the job requires a lifetime waiting
for today
he pledged not to be served but to serve
a day full of traditions and ceremonial
procedure from the past but also a day
which looks forward to a new style of
monarchy
King Charles and the whole country
reflecting on what lies ahead
and how this most ancient of
Institutions can continue to serve the
nation